you probably don't need any more reason
to be frustrated as you Wade through the
holiday crowds to buy the cheap plastic
toy gifts for your children that you
know will all be lost or broken within
three and a half hours of being opened
on Christmas morning but I will give you
another reason anyway so consider that
according to the latest data a
significant portion of the adults in
that crowd are buying toys not for
children but for themselves
in fact if you're not able to find the
exact Barbie playset or Batman action
figure or whatever that you're looking
for it could be because some adult has
already purchased the last one
not for his kid but for himself CNBC
reports this morning about a new group
of consumers that have been dubbed kids
alts
these uh emotionally stunted
intellectually shallow overgrown ever
overgrown adolescence well into their
30s or 40s and yet apparently still I
don't know riding around on Big Wheels
drinking their juice boxes may be
destroying Society but they're doing
wonders for the toy industry so that's
the good news this is from the report it
says there are two things keeping the
toy industry afloat right now inflation
and a consumer group known as cadults
these kids at heart are responsible for
one-fourth of all toy sales annually
around nine billion dollars worth and
are the biggest driver of growth
throughout the industry according to
data from the NPD group
this cohort which NPD defines as ages 12
and older has been steadily contributing
to the industry for years but spending
has accelerated in the wake of the
pandemic leading to year-over-year gains
despite tough comparisons it's an
industry moment for the toy industry
it's an important moment for the toy
industry too with the holiday season
upon us while sales surged across the
board for board games puzzles and
playsets during the pandemic the first
nine months of 2022 saw a three percent
decline in sales volume higher toy
prices helped outweigh these losses as
sales revenue for the time period jumped
three percent NPD reported cadults who
tend to spend more on toys have a great
fondness for cartoons superheroes and
collectibles that remind them of their
childhood they buy merchandise such as
action figures Lego sets and dolls that
might typically be considered for kids
however in recent years toy makers have
created product Lines Just for these
consumers realizing that demand is high
for this generation of adults who still
want to have fun
so as the economy struggles and more and
more adults drop out of the workforce
entirely adults are at the same time
spending more money than ever on
children's toys for themselves
I hate to be the bearer of bad news here
but this is um not a sign of a healthy
Society now granted if 12 years old is
the cutoff then some of these cadults
are actually just kids
and the good news is that if your 12
year old is still playing with Legos
that's uh that's a great sign actually
he has his innocence still and Legos are
a hell of a lot more wholesome and
productive than staring at screens all
day as most 12 year olds do these days
unfortunately
so that's fantastic a 12 year old
playing with Legos but the fact remains
that a great number of the people in
this demographic are in fact actual
adults Millennials and gen xers who
refuse to let go of their childhoods no
matter what
The Today Show highlights uh some more
of the people in this group let's watch
Ruckus
toys
everybody knows the song it's that
classes 80s commercial from Toys R Us
and it turns out a kid can always be a
kid it's true there's a growing Trend
that finds more and more adults buying
toys for themselves the group being
called kiddles and it's proving to be a
very big business and our kid at heart
NBC News Now anchored Joe fires here
with more this is a thing huh yeah good
morning I don't want to grow up either
you know new data is showing that people
age 12 and older those are adults 12 and
older they now make up at least a
quarter of toy consumers and the
industry is cashing in with new products
marketed specifically toward Millennials
even gen xers
toys of Christmas Past are now
revisiting many in their adulthood from
adult Happy Meals here are the fries
and then a toy
Barbie to Barbie who's starring in a new
movie coming out next summer
Nostalgia is a driving force for a
growing consumer group called The Kid
alt CNBC reports that data from market
research company NPD group show adults
who are young at heart spend about nine
billion dollars annually for the past
two plus years adults really started to
gravitate towards toys and games not
just to spend more time with their
families which they were doing at home
but also for themselves to de-stress
Aaron muterick is a former software
engineer turned connoisseur of putty he
says grown-ups are stuck on reliving
simpler times from their childhood I
think there is some level of nostalgia
Putty was introduced in the late 1950s
to Children we've seen it time and again
where adults maybe think it is four
children but then once they touch the
putty that their children have they they
want one for themselves
God help us all I mean it's gotten to
the point where adults who play video
games all day are essentially this
generation's version of a man reading a
leather-bound book in his study while
smoking a pipe I mean the gamer is
mature and refined compared to a 40 year
old man who sits around playing with
silly putty all day now what's the
problem here well the situation the
situation already feels rather hopeless
based on the fact that we even need to
explain the problem what's the problem
with adults sitting around all day
playing with toys I I mean it should be
self-evident that your Society is not in
Tip-Top shape when adults are spending
billions of dollars on children's toys
that they will play with themselves
shows not only a catastrophic lack of
maturity in the culture but also a
misalignment of priorities a level of
shallow materialism that is certainly
unprecedented in the history of the
world I mean this this would all seem to
me to be totally self-evident but if I
must flesh it out then I would simply
make
the following observation so first
nobody is saying that we should not have
fun as adults there's nothing wrong with
fun and Recreation on the contrary these
are important parts of a whole and
well-lived life
yet everything must be done in the right
proportion and in a way that is properly
ordered our trouble is that Recreation
has become the primary if not sole focus
of many people's lives and what's more
their idea of recreation their idea of
fun
has not grown or evolved over time they
have grown physically but their tastes
have not
this is one of the most glaring signs of
emotional immaturity and the thing about
emotionally immature people is that if
you ever talk about the problem of
immaturity they will laugh at you which
is exactly how you would expect an
immature person to respond
of course if we lived in a culture that
was filled with mature interesting
competent adults adults with useful
skills adults capable of having
intelligent conversations able to grasp
and to express nuanced ideas adults who
eagerly accept the duties and
responsibilities of adulthood Etc if
that was the case
and still many of these adults also
happen to be obsessed with superheroes
and cartoons and action figures then we
might just chalk it up to a weird sort
of Quirk or eccentricity in our culture
and not really worry much about it
beyond that
but that is not the sort of culture that
we find ourselves in instead we are
surrounded
by Immature idiots who have the skill
sets reasoning skills and Ambitions and
motivations of children
and they also happen to have the hobbies
and Recreations of children and so we
can conclude I think logically
that all of these things are probably
related that the billions spent on the
toys the obsession with Nostalgia is
both a symptom and a driver of the
overall problem
and the overall problem is that the real
business of adulthood is being delayed
and sometimes shirked entirely this is
uh most obvious when we see the numbers
of people refusing to start families and
have kids of their own I mean it's no
surprise
that that's the case given that that you
know they see themselves as kids so they
don't want to have kids
and since that's how they've chosen to
live they also don't realize
that not only is it possible to have fun
as an adult like an adult but you can
even be a real adult
and still enjoy the toys and games of
childhood
like I'm not even saying that when you
become an adult you can never pick up a
toy ever again
but here's the difference
you know those childhood toys
you're supposed to be playing with those
with your own kids I was just playing
with Batman action figures yesterday
okay just yesterday I was but I was
playing with my son it was something I
was doing with him
I wouldn't sit down on the floor by
myself and play with Batman toys
because I'm a grown man and there was a
time when a grown man sitting on the
floor and playing with action figures by
himself would be immediately seen as
mentally handicapped and probably
institutionalized for it
yet when you're playing with your
children it's a different story I have
indeed experienced once again many of
the joys of a of childhood
but from the perspective of an adult who
is now helping to introduce those Joys
to my own children and the joy that I
derive from it now is largely in seeing
and being a part of their Joy this is
supposed to be one of the Hallmarks of a
stable functional well-rounded adult
that you learn how to find happiness in
helping other people to be happy
now another Point here I made the same
observation when we were uh discussing
the adult Happy Meals a few weeks ago
and and you know we hear so much about
how
um my generation and is obsessed with
Nostalgia this is like the millennial
things always talking about their
Nostalgia constantly pining for the
innocence of their childhood growing up
in the 90s you know and there's
something wrong with nostalgia
unless it totally consumes your life and
becomes your entire personality
but also think about what they are
nostalgic for
their Nostalgia is all tied to Brands
their Nostalgia is is a corporate
invention they're nostalgic for Consumer
products they're nostalgic for
entertainment franchises
it is a very particular very modern kind
of nostalgia that is easy for Brands to
exploit and monetize because they
invented it
but it's not the kind of nostalgia that
drives people towards better more
complete and fulfilling lives it just
doesn't now a Nostalgia for experience
a Nostalgia for family Nostalgia for
actual meaningful events that you uh
went through and experience as a child
that can drive you in a good and
worthwhile way
so you know I I find myself nostalgic
for the family dinners that we would
have when I was a child with my parents
and my five brothers and sisters and we
would all sit around and have these big
dinners and uh I can be nostalgic for
that well guess what now I have six kids
of my own
and I find myself back at the dinner
table again with four of them because
two are still unborn but I find myself
back at the dinner dinner table again
recapturing that experience and passing
it down to my kids
who I hope will pass it to theirs and so
on that's the sort of generational
passing that we're supposed to be doing
not passing down
entertainment franchises
I remember when I watched this franchise
when I was a child and that it's like
experience things that you did things
that meant something that's what you're
supposed to be passing down
to your kids the problem is that so many
in my generation they were they were
latchkey kids who came home to empty
houses and divorced parents and ate
dinner on the couch watching TV
and so their Nostalgia is not for the
experience
but for the thing they were watching
last point you know you notice the way
that things have completely flipped
upside down
we have these adults
clinging to their childhoods
while at the same time we rip the
childhood away from actual children
so children have their innocence stolen
by groomers in public schools by you
know early exposure to porn and all of
the debased and degraded things that
kids are exposed to intentionally all
the time and it's this it's this
mechanism which is which is intended to
corrupt children to destroy their
innocence
and at the same time when Society is
engineering this corruption it is also
beckoning towards adults telling them to
come back and become kids again
it's almost like we're trying to switch
places
it's totally inverted and perverse
and and we need to flip things back
around and set it right let the kids be
kids they're the kids let them if you're
going to be obsessed with Nostalgia and
childhood innocence be obsessed with
protecting the innocence of actual
children it's their turn to be kids now
we had our chance it's over
we're adults now
let the kids be kids
you know there's a reason why scripture
says when I was a child I spoke as a
child I understood as a child I thought
as a child but when I became a man I put
away childish things
it is time to do that
well past time
to put away the childish things
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show is move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]